alright Henry what should be the topic
of my question Tuesday video Alice what
should my questions use the video will
be about monkey turtles good morning
Hank it's Tuesday it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters about pokemons
and monkey turtles oh and video we're
all here together in the desert I don't
know what monkey turtles are I also
didn't know what a monkey turtle was so
I asked Alice and she said it's a monkey
that turns into a turtle right Yeah
right for why oh I asked her that and
she said for protection then I asked
Alice how big monkey turtles were and
she said 100 big it's big well or not
it's true it depends on if it's
millimeters you need to learn units
talking to Alice is like talking to a
not very good AI she's like a bad chat
but yeah she said to me uncle Hank I got
this new water bottle and I said is it
better than your old water bottle and
she said it's pink the others purple
like it's like I asked you a question
you entered a different question where I
kind of we're on the same topic she's
also like a jet but in that a lot of
times if you ask her a question she'll
say I don't want to talk about that what
is your favorite Pokemon and why is it
Charizard it's not Charizard it's
Snorlax because he's cute and large and
powerful mine is Andrew Andrew
yeah view have you seen Andrew Pokemon
is he a monkey turtle no it's just a guy
plays guitar
what Pokemon could best keep a steady
job Oh probably Andrew put it in your
head
Charizard managing like a Wendy's and
it'd be like the grill breaks he's just
gone all the burger oh my god he can
cook the burgers oh wow what is the most
underrated Pokemon oh I think the most
underrated Pokemon is surfing Pikachu
I'm gonna go with like the the wiggle
puffed Jigglypuff or spike ladder spike
ladder that's a real one jacent you ask
Henry what he wants to be when he grows
up he says inventor and then he pauses
it and says of Pokemon John yes how
could I be the very best like no one
ever was come on if you had to
permanently dye your hair a non-natural
color what would it be
silver ooh well you're getting there
already I know I'm on my way when I was
in college I thought to myself I want to
have a job when when I turned 40 I can
get
Mohawk mm-hmm and now I do hey welcome
to crash course biochemistry it's me
your cool teacher Hank with the 40 year
old mobile doesn't all value derive from
humans hmm no I just want to say for the
record Hank he's not taller than I am
it's just that he is standing on a rock
I was down hill Hank what is your
favorite adjective to throw in when you
want to spice up a sentence spicy I
don't like that at all what do you think
of that three-point shot Hank spicy I
don't want to be like my friends will be
like yeah Hank the one who says spicy
all the time oh yeah Hank spicy green
they call them oh who would win in a
fight between a monkey turtle and a
turtle monkey oh definitely a monkey
turtle because it could turn into a
turtle for protection what is your
favorite type of plate Oh for me it's
the kind that the Earth's crust is on
ooh
I mean those are good sometimes you're
at a really fancy restaurant and there's
a plate on the table before the food
comes out and then they take that plate
away yes and I'm like what was that
right why was that plate there yeah just
in case flying it to me it's just in
case plate would you rather have c-3po
in your house or r2d2 r2d2 because like
like whenever I hang out with you I kind
of feel like I do have c-3po in my house
it's true hey what Pokemon do you think
looks the most like you I don't know
either but I'm excited to find out from
my viewers isn't mr. mime the only one
that walks on two feet uh I mean like
it's vaguely human state I don't know of
a greater insult than saying that
someone looks like mr. mime we're gonna
go keep walking so goodbye friends bye
I'll see you now well you want to see
our incredibly sophisticated tripod by
the way it's Hanks wallet and two rocks
dude OOP